hey guys what's up this is andrew for
consensus.com
so as usual i'm here to make some
technical analysis i'm here to show you
everything that i like to use when i was
a professional trader
all the different tools and techniques
that worked for me all these years
and i want to show you guys how this is
working and how to do it yourself
so in this video i want to make a big
update guys on the cryptocurrency market
especially on the bitcoin so let's get
into it
[Music]
and guys so it's been a long time i
didn't make a video on the bitcoin so
let me
remind you first as usual
what was my last scenario
in the update i think i did around two
or three weeks ago
so let's take a step back here and let
me make me
make a full analysis and remind you guys
what
happened and what is probably gonna
happen so maybe we can start on the
weekly time frame here
take a big step back and i just want to
show you guys that
here since inception we're doing a one
in purple
this one a one two three four and five
so we are in the fifth wave
since february 19 since we reached
3 000 and in this fifth wave
here we're doing a one two three four
five and the second wave
button in march 20 during the coverage
and since
then we're having this amazing bull run
that started from three four thousand
and that went to 75
so now i'm gonna zoom in inside this
five wave development here
but we are only in the third wave guys
in this five wave developments
so i think the third wave is complete
now
so this was actually everything that i
was showing you guys
in my previous videos you can go and
check it out that's still on my channel
i was basically telling you in this
whole i know i have a lot of drawings
here guys but
i'm gonna show you what you need to be
focused on
so here now i'm zooming in and i
analyze this third wave guys so the wave
that started here
in the 31st march 2020 and that finished
at
65 000 and once again
the whole move up so this third wave of
course
will be broken down in five waves
because we are following elliot waves
principle that is saying that moves up
developing five waves and moves down
correct in three waves abc flat zigzag
or in five waves abcde in a triangle
so here we had this first
wave to 12 000 then here correction i
think i started to do my
videos here and i was telling you guys
we're gonna have
an amazing strong move up because i knew
we were in the third
of my third which is usually the most
impulsive and the strongest
wave and this one went to 45 and here i
told you guys
it's time to buy because i spotted that
we were having here this triangle that
is a false wave
you can see it very clearly here and
that's usually after triangles just like
we have on amc guys
after triangles we often have i mean
almost always having a fifth wave
you can find it here this is elliot wave
course guys that i use a lot
it's my bible and here i'm just
showing you guys something that is
interesting for you to know
okay triangles nearly always occurring
on positions prior to the final
actionary
wave so this is what we're having on amc
and this is what we had
here and then we had our fifth wave so
during the fifth wave
i was telling you guys this is the fixed
wave be careful
we are starting to see some weakness so
here we had a lot of weaknesses
first we had so here one two three four
five you can see that the false wave
in this pattern is entering wave one
territory this is an ending diagonal
once again you can find it here
okay ending diagonals take a wedge shape
within
two converging lines which each sub wave
including wave one
three and five subdividing into a three
which is otherwise a corrective pattern
pattern
a corrective wave phenomenon i'm not
gonna go through
all of this with you guys but basically
ending diagonals just like
the name states and our final waves
of larger degree patterns so here it was
my fifth wave
and i had of course as usual a nice
bearish divergence you can see
market making higher highs like from one
to five and the macd during the same
time was making
lower highs so this is the divergence so
this is the reason why
here when we broke my watch pattern
around
60 000 i told you guys i told you i gave
you the strength i said the bitcoin is
gonna go
much lower uh i had 42 000 as a target
because it's the top of the third wave
but
uh it can also go to 28 000 the bottom
of my force wave
so the second case was the one that
actually happened
and so right now i just wanted to go
with you guys
through all of this analysis because
it's very important to understand what
is going to happen right now
all right so now we understand that we
finished this
third wave and that we're doing a force
so we are right now doing this fourth
wave so let me just
put this one all right so we are doing
this false wave so we are wondering what
kind of pattern we can have
here and i'm coming to this i'm gonna
give you guys what you're here
for i'm gonna give you my different
scenarios i'm gonna give you my
preferred scenario i'm gonna give you my
targets and i'm gonna tell you when this
is probably gonna happen
so we went to the bottom of the force
wave so we are wondering
when this correction is going to be
complete so to do that
to know to get this information we need
to analyze what kind of pattern
is actually happening here so let me
zoom in
even more and i'm right now expecting a
correction
of a larger degree wave counting so i'm
expecting this correction to be a bit
long so i told you in my previous videos
that we're gonna have probably a rebound
around
june or july it can go up to august or
september it wouldn't be a problem
you can see just visually having your
correction coming to september
makes sense as well so for now i don't
have this information i don't know how
long it's gonna last
but my guess is maybe a bit more and i'm
gonna explain to you guys why
so the very first thing is that we need
to label what is happening here
and you're gonna see guys i have very
interesting information right now i'm
gonna give you
so look at this now
we focus only on what happens from here
so we have the a
b c so let me get rid of that for now
okay we're having an abc and
here it it's very interesting guys
because look what happened
so we don't know if it's gonna be an abc
or if it's gonna be a one two three four
five
all right this is a question we're
having because if it's a one two three
four five then it's a motive wave then
we know that we're gonna have an abc
going higher and then that we're gonna
have another
one two three four five do you
understand because if you have five
waves
then the motif waves are going down then
you usually have a corrective pattern
that is going to go up
and then one more motif wave that is
going to go down
and then it means that we're going to
correct too much lower levels probably
20 000
so this was one of my scenario and
i want to show you guys really this
because it's
what happened here is very very very
interesting
i'm going to invert the scale because we
are used to look
at charts that go higher so and here i
just want to show you
what happened we we had i think
manipulation of the market
quite obvious here because as you can
see
if i don't label this abc here i have a
one i have a two so this is the new move
after
this is my watch pattern that broke this
is sixty thousand
here first wave second wave correction
then the third wave
and here guys we're having a beautiful
triangle in the false wave
and we had to break out here and then
something very very bullish i mean this
here
something very very bullish happened
because we had to break out
usually we should have had this fifth
wave that would tell me that
we're gonna go much lower that probably
then correct and go lower just like i
showed you probably to
20 000 area but this breakout guys is to
me a clear
sign of market manipulation this usually
if it would have happened in a healthy
market we should have
had this big correction that would
follow
and for me what happened is that a lot
of traders
big traders that own probably a lot of
crypto a lot of bitcoin
they knew that there were a lot of stop
losses here they saw the pattern that
was getting drawn
and they probably pushed the price lower
here
because they knew that they would buy
together at 30 000
so for me this is just a trick to push
some buyers to stop the positions so
basically this is a domino effect
created by stop losses
almost sure of that in all this area
guys
from here to here it's stop losses
and usually i don't understand why this
market managed to go higher
this is probably because there were a
lot of buyers at the 30 000 area
but if there were so many buyers at the
30 000 area i don't understand why this
has broken
and why it has not gone lower so this is
to me
a fake out so let's check the volumes
the volumes are gonna give us some
information here
you have an increase in the volume so
you know it it looks really like a
breakout
but for some reason it didn't go lower i
you know it happens so for this i have
no explanation my only explanation
is that there were some buyers that
agreed together
to buy a big big quantity of bitcoin
at this level so they managed to push
the price higher so
given that now i know that it is not a
one two three four five i know that
we're only having an abc
abc so i know this is corrective this
triangle
is not holding anymore and now
what i can only expect is actually after
this correction either we go right away
higher but as you can see
actually here we're having some weakness
let me show you guys this again i told
you about divergences just before
look here if we if we connect the highs
of this move
and then we connect the highs on the
macd you can see that we have
a bearish hidden divergence let me show
you guys quickly what is a bearish
hidden divergence it's this one
so it's the market making lower highs
even
if the momentum indicator is making
higher highs so you know you should see
some momentum some bullish momentum in
the market
you should see a higher high but the
market is not able
to give it the market is stuck and still
going lower even
when we have some bullish momentum so
this is showing
weakness and we're having this weakness
here you can see
and on the macd is not very clear to me
because you know the magnet is going
higher but you see that the highs are
not connected perfectly so in these
situations
i like to add the rsi
and with the rsi you can see you can do
this divergence with any momentum
indicator rsi
stochastic macd and on the rsi it's very
clear
divergence is obvious you see here rsi
going higher the market going lower
so to sum up the situation i'm having an
abc
not a one two three four five so this is
corrective but
i'm having some weaknesses here and i
think i'm seeing some
market manipulation that is buying the
market so
the market is strong the market is
strong
we corrected to the bottom of the force
wave but we're having a bearish
divergence
so i think that what is happening is a
complex correction
and complex corrections once again you
can check
in the elliot wave pdf that is on google
just type idiot wave theory
by pressed and thruster and you're going
to find this
and those complex corrections they look
like this you have sometimes a zigzag
w x y so it can be a zigzag
flat triangle you know and they just
they get called sideways combination of
corrective patterns double threes and
triple threes
while within your three blah blah blah
is a combination of simple types of
corrections
including the various types of zigzags
flats and triangles all right so this is
what we had in gamestop by the way
two months ago and you know complex
corrections are not easy to
actually trade because it's usually
messy
the signals are not very clean you don't
really understand what the market wants
to do because it just wants to correct
it just needs time
and here i think that what we need is
time
so my scenario right now is that we're
doing something like this abc
okay so abc
then here a second abc and i think we're
gonna do
one more so we're gonna have three so i
don't know if it's gonna be a triangle
sometimes it triangles so let me put
here a triangle usually the last pattern
of a w
x y correction is also a triangle so it
might be something like this
so i'm just giving you here an example
but it can be anything
actually it can be a flatter triangle
it's exactly we don't know but i mix i
think
that here the price action might be
rejected at the 42 000 level which is
for me the strongest
resistance we have in here and i think
that this market look
look at the bigger so let me get rid of
the rsi now so i have a lighter chart
and if i take a step back guys
look this market last time the
correction last
from july 19 to march 20 so basically
eight months
so now it's been three months we're in
it so i think that
you know having two three more months
would make sense
so maybe we would even have a longer
correction but it can be as well shorter
so
basically i don't know i'm expecting one
or two few
more corrective patterns to happen
because i'm having this bearish
divergence i can see the market is very
strong so i think it's going to hold
and here if we having
a breakout of the 42 000 level it means
that we already having our one two three
four five
so this is the way it's gonna end guys
probably
it's gonna end like this once this
corrective pattern is gonna be finished
we're gonna have at some point so it can
happen now maybe it's happening now guys
maybe
we having already a one two
three four five maybe this is happening
but if it's not happening and we're
having one more corrective pattern
then the one two three four five would
just come later but
ultimately we're gonna complete this
fifth wave we have
one more wave guys one more wave to go
higher
and let me just give you the target
quickly and this
next wave would probably go i just use
fibs
guys here up i measured the third wave
i applied to the bottom of the force
wave and it's giving me
133 000 so this is my target for the
bitcoin
probably around next year july next year
probably
in one year so this is where i see the
bitcoin in one year for just the reason
i gave you so i think we have time
this market needs to correct a bit more
uh there was a lot of damage created
two months ago we don't know what china
is going to do with crypto as well
so all of this will impact the price
action so we need to stay focused on
here
we have a strong support at thirty
thousand the resistance is forty
thousand if we break it and retest it's
a nice level to buy otherwise would be a
buy
around thirty thousand and i would keep
an eye on those corrective patterns
that's probably gonna keep happening
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys